this game it's win by two not here it's
not
hey they letting yoga instructor's in
the gym now
well I just noticed you're not getting
enough legs under the shot are you
dehydrated 100 bucks you can't make more
shots let's just do 300. it's not my
dad's money
they ain't never gonna get a reparation
that way bro so I prefer venmo or Zell
but you seem like a cash app guy so
huh it's showing up the course dressed
like a dumbass acting like you can't who
you assumed I couldn't who because I'm
white which is incredibly outdated I
assumed you couldn't hoop because you
were dressed like a white girl at Whole
Foods
it's really hard to plan for the future
when we're always worried about money
because you're out here living in a
fantasy my 30-day detox program I want a
free sample no I ain't drinking no
boo-boo juice babe it's almost the first
I'm gonna go tomorrow I forgot why don't
you just go now it'll be fine hey don't
worry mommy don't worry Mommy
every Hooper I know is entering that big
ass tournament with a winner get 500
000. I just need somebody who can play
so I can make some money
you're joking right 500 000 for one day
I hope yeah yeah yeah we could hustle a
few games together to get the money for
the entry fee I'll find some marks those
short shorts look incredible throw them
off their game you have the only fast
and we'll clean up you're gonna wear
that trash bag you can wear that fake
ass Richard Simmons outfit
bro I bet you all got more in common
than me release for me
release for me
don't spend any money until we can cover
the feet I should be saying that to you
well I'm good with money so am I so am I
me too me too where where are you bruh
okay I'll see you
buckets what I just wanted to see if you
had superhuman hearing because of you
cause my what
they're gonna kill him in the parking
lot I'm out of here he got a
flamethrower flamethrower what is this
Mad Max
bro I don't know how much you talking to
your ass later today good work thank you
you can talk way more trash out there
you have so much material I can't even
touch
like what
never mind oh
tell us what a Love Goes
[Music]
foreign